blakely has the most difficult job at
the cincinnati zoo he has to play with
babies all the time
he's never shown any aggression or
snapped if he gets upset kind of like
any mom would he just leaves the room
you are so cute
my name is don strasser and we're at the
cincinnati zoo and botanical gardens
blakely is a five-year-old australian
shepherd we got him from a rescue and i
use him in a nursery as a nanny or a
companion dog this is about you and
you're taking a nap blakely's here for
the main purpose of teaching the babies
the correct animal cues as they grow up
so when they are introduced back to
their own kind they know what
appropriate behavior is he teaches them
how to play how to interact
i can tell him no don't bite me but
i'm not an animal and i don't give the
same cues that he can
so we make a great team
smile what are they going to do for a
camera
camera
blakely has worked with cheetahs
ocelots
a talking
battered foxes
a warthog
wallabies
to name a few he's working with four
baby cheetahs right now
it's been a long seven weeks for him
with these little cheetah cubs and he's
i think tired because he's on alert for
24 hours a day if they start making too
much noise he'll come and get us like
something's not right something's not
right
he's kind of like a second set of eyes
for us too a lot of times they still
recognize each other like dale the talk
and he raised when they see each other
he'll they'll still run up up front and
grunt at him and he'll kind of jump up
on the wall and it's kind of like hey
how you doing
he's beautiful thank you
yeah well i i like to think i have an
office but i'm pretty sure it's his